following a tumultuous year within
district leadership and a number of
recent violent incidents on campus ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
delivering his state of the school's
address earlier today all right so this
year's theme is emerging stronger
together mary jane belliesa shares what
dr jarrah wants the district to
concentrate on moving forward
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
highlighted many key points including a
plan to improve school proficiency curb
violence in schools and ways to support
teachers and students
dr jarrah discussed how to move
education forward citing the community
needs to hold the district accountable
to ensure the plan moves in the right
direction we have to support our schools
our teachers and not their professional
learning our leaders are doing a great
job in really building that
instructional leadership how do we
monitor instruction how do we monitor
support dr jarrah also addressed violent
incidents on campuses he wants to make
sure teachers get support in the
classroom to feel safe he also addressed
students that had been expelled and
disciplinary policies we presented to
the board last night
on our
our school justice partnership and all
our discipline
from day one i've said you know i don't
tolerate
the violence
but we can just throw kids on the street
another goal hire more than 1 600
teachers in one year with recruiting not
only in state but out of state too it's
one of those reach goals that my hr team
the 25 percent
we're going to double down we need them
now dr jarrah plans to also focus on
mental and emotional health for students
and staff reversing the pandemic impacts
on the district as well as having better
expectations moving forward reporting
from caesar's palace mary jane baleza
live local now